bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous la pandémie qui pourrait donc
entraîner la plus profonde récession
économique de notre existence selon l'om
c'est d'abord cette déclaration comment
en prendre les choses bonjour
écoutez je suis pour une fois c'est
d'accord avec les analyses de l'om c'est
suffisamment rare pour être souligné
effectivement on va rentrer dans une
récession est dans une situation
économique extrêmement grave
elle aurait été peut-être un peu moins
grave si les gouvernements des prix
cette pandémie plus au sérieux et avait
fait le nécessaire en amont pour se
procurer les masques le gel
hydroalcoolique les respirateurs et tout
ce qui fait défaut aujourd'hui mais en
effet on va rentrer dans une récession
grave à laquelle il s'agit de faire face
avec des mesures extrêmement forte et
extrêmement fine en même temps la france
elle est déjà rentré enfin on est déjà
rentré en récession est officiellement
aujourd'hui et on est même dans le pire
scénario donc la récession c'est une
baisse en face est une baisse du pib
consécutifs pendant deux semaines ce
trou deux trimestres de puisqu'on parle
de trimestre effectivement nous sommes
rentrés en récession c'est la pire
récession depuis 1945 et face à une
telle situation il va falloir prendre
des mesures de relance budgétaire
extrêmement forte et ça ne m'étonne pas
que l'union européenne avec 110 des au
logis avec ses traités ne soit pas à la
hauteur du rendez vous qui s'annonce
face à cette récession il va falloir
mettre de côté tous les traités
européens qui nous limite la taille du
déficit public qui nous oblige à
retourner à moyen terme à l'équilibré
c'est-à-dire le traité de maastricht le
pacte budgétaire dit traité sur la
stabilité la coordination et la
gouvernance et relancer massivement
notre économie par des mesures de
demandes
c'est peut-être le moment de mettre en
oeuvre ce qui a été évoqué d'ailleurs
par la commission le green new deal
européen c'est-à-dire une une dépense
massive par la transition écologique et
peut-être de mettre en place une la
garantie d'emploi qui a été proposé par
un certain nombre de deux députés
européens mais qui pour l'instant n'est
pas reprise au niveau européen
alors justement au niveau européen il ya
eu cette réunion des ministres de
2 les milices de la zone euro il n'y a
pas d'accord pour l'instant ils vont à
nouveau se réunir demain est ce qu on
est au bord de l'implosion là au niveau
européen finalement parce que personne
n'arrive à s'entendre on a effectivement
un grand écart en particulier entre
l'italie qui va plutôt dans le sens de
ce que je viens d'exprimer c'est à dire
la nécessité d'une relance la nécessité
de re h et les contraintes la volonté de
mettre en oeuvre des bons du trésor au
niveau européen pour faire face à cette
situation
puis de l'autre côté les pays bas qui ne
veulent pas en entendre parler et
l'allemagne va être largement coupable
de l'échec des négociations qui
s'annoncent
on arrivera peut-être un accord mais qui
va déboucher sur une souris et moi ma
crainte c'est que tout reparte comme en
2008 2009 où les gouvernements européens
n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
elle n'a eu un ensemble de sommet pour
sauver la zone euro qui finalement
débouché sur des traités encore plus
problématique traitée qui ne sont pas du
tout adaptés à la situation actuelle et
qui vont devoir être révisé
drastiquement
si on veut sortir de la nasse et delà de
cette situation exceptionnelle qui
s'annonce extrêmement difficile pour
l'ensemble de nos économies est ce qu'il
y a des solutions pour s'en sortir
à mon sens du côté de l'offre c'est
plutôt des politiques sectorielles qu'il
va falloir mener regarder très
précisément les secteurs qui sont en
tension des secteurs qui sûrement suivre
est évitée et qui sont potentiellement
une source d'inflation localiser et d'un
autre côté relancer massivement la
demande donc une fois de plus ça passe à
la transition écologique
ça passe par une relocalisation aussi
d'un certain nombre d'activités
ça passe par un green new deal européen
qui aujourd'hui n'est hélas pas l'ordre
du jour dani lang devait permettre une
question parce que je crois savoir comme
avez vous même été atteint ducobu 19
comment vous allez écouter moi je vais
bien et j'ai eu la chance de ne pas
avoir de complications respiratoires
bon c'est quand même plus une une petite
grille donc vraiment rester chez vous
parce que c'est une grosse grippe à ces
fâcheuses et à ces traîtres parce que ça
commence doucement à ça se complique
vous avez vous avez pris un traitement
particulier au nom du doliprane
est ce qu'il fallait face aux aux
conséquences de la maladie j'ai pas eu
accès à l'accueil qui nous traitement
actuellement expérimentés merci à daniel
lang pour cette intervention en direct
sur arte france rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université de
paris xiii merci à vous merci à vous